ce monsieur est maintenant à parler d'un
documentaire qui va faire le buzz le 29
mars et peut le dire c'est johnny par
johnny des images dina des images qui
ont été données par les très proches
adeline blondieau et parmi les deux
proches de pointe là pour nous parler
gilles l'autre et ami et biographe
officiel de johnny je peux vous dire que
là c'est du lourd et benjamin locoge
rédacteur en chef de culture à paris
match qu'il a rencontré aussi et qui est
très très très calé merci d accueillir
[Applaudissements]
ça
c'est à l'origine ce lot je peux vous
appeler gilles ça serait bien oui sinon
ça serait mieux c'est à c'est un honneur
de faire si le drapeau officiel dont
vous connaissez très très très très bien
johnny hallyday et puis benjamin par l
on vous a fait dans un documentaire
pardon à qu'on a produit pour cette
chaîne et vous avez été la star des
documentaires merci
à lodja comment comment voulez vous avez
créé par poser la question autrement qu
est ce que vous pensez de ce
documentaire qui sort ou c'est johnny
par johnny n'ont fait que des images
d'archivés des images qui ont été
données ou on va découvrir johnny
j'allais dire un peu sombre aille à
l'alcool et à la drogue et les bagarres
ya le rock'n'roll ya tout mais est ce
qu'on a besoin de savoir tout ça sur
l'idole à willy si bien sûr qu'on a
envie de savoir tout ouais on a déjà
tellement toudic on se dit qu'est ce
qu'on peut savoir de plus donc oui il ya
toujours une fascination monumental pour
le personnage pour pourquoi pas ce
qu'est ce que c'était que ces fameux
démons dont on parle depuis depuis des
années et puis johnny fait johnny fait
vente je n'y fais vivre johnny voilà il
y avait dès qu'on apprend plus sur lui
c'est un peu du sale pardon non qu'est
ce qui est plus à savoir voilà là ce
documentaire raconte en profondeur des
choses dont on a déjà parlé on peut
regarder la bande annonce et la gare et
on en parle regardez c'est un jour où tu
étais vraiment dégoûté par toi
ouais
[Musique]
et tu regrettes bien sûr non je suis
génial idée je vais vous partagez le fil
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
soixante dix joly est au creux de la
main je n'écris de cafard immense des
fois puisque je me sens seul
terriblement seul canton à guéret au
bord du gouffre
[Musique]
de donner un coup depuis d'augmenter
[Applaudissements]
je suis plus là en fin de compte
elle y
participer vous avez été relevé pour
documentaires seront pas et alors vous
avez vous avez tout dit à vous parler de
plein de choses ou parler notamment deux
pas de la drogue vous parlez de l'alcool
vous parler de tentatives de suicide de
toutes ces choses que vous avez connu
avec johnny star mais j'parle par sa non
non je ne sais bien je sais bien il est
chose positive que vous dites aussi mais
vous savez bien que quand on sera donc
comme ça c'est ce qu'on va retenir non
parce qu'il n'ya pas que ça ça veut dire
ces cinq épisodes de 35 minutes
absolument donc vous imaginez bien que
il on me fait un trailer sur ce qui va
fracasser bas j'entends bien alors moi
j'ai quand même quelques voilà quelques
révélations de gilles dote d'un
documentaire à la drogue par exemple
vous dit un soir à cannes nanette et moi
à son livre donc net s'est lui assez de
cette jolie pardon et sa copine de
l'époque on se fait des lignes de coke
sur le capot de la rolls elle dégaine la
première en riant elle elle se tape des
lignes de coke tout seul vous dites ça
prenait la dose à l'époque il a eu il a
été très très triste parce qu'il avait
une rupture film a un chagrin d'amour
merci beaucoup et derrière eu beaucoup
de rôles beaucoup d'alcool c'est tout ce
que vous dites dedans quand même tout ça
français
c'est dans le livre ça même si vous avez
très bien que l'on se sent des trucs
comme ça oui bien sûr en fait ça a été
tirée d'un johnny tenait ce que il
m'avait demandé en 96 de l'aider à
écrire son autobiographie
parce que justement il trouvait que tout
ce qui avait été fait jusqu'à maintenant
supervisé par gilles paquet qui était
son son attaché de presse historique et
être au lycée ah oui parce qu'en fait je
lis c'est un personnage qui est
profondément tragique qui te si tragique
les romantiques
atypique et qui est c'est vrai poursuivi
par des démons de l'abandon de la
solitude et c'est un personnage beaucoup
plus complexe qu'on peut le croire le
père de laeticia ds et un c'est un
rocker dépressif drogués et alcooliques
moi ça c'est pas mal il énoncé le père
de laeticia donc wayne rooney s'est pas
non bien sûr mais voilà comme il le
qualifie ouais je trouve ça un peu short
quand même la définition
parce que vous allez voir quand même que
le
que ce document est un peu exceptionnel
parce que c'est johnny qui raconte tu es
là c'est ça qu'est ce que ces tirs et
d'image de li na waie d'image qui ont
été données par universal qui avait
qu'est ce qu'on va justement apprendre
qu'on ne connaissait pas déjà vous allez
découvrir plein de choses parce qu'il ya
des tas de choses qu'on connaît pas ça
fait ça fait combien de temps deux ans
qu'on a travaillé là-dessus n'en est il
avait travaillé deux ans avant donc si
vous voulez c'est quand même un travail
au long cours
et quand on sait que johnny quand on
travaillait à l'époque un match pour
travailler sur johnny vous travaillez
sur des archives qui sont aussi
importantes que celles du général de
gaulle ou de brigitte bardot temps sont
désormais plus sa phénoménale il démarre
avec le général de gaulle et termine
avec macron way entre les deux îles des
bandes pas
valider certaines choses laeticia
hallyday est là elle a vu le nombre
d'artistes intérieur et laeticia
hallyday les ans on était six hallyday
david hallyday tout l'entourage proche a
refusé de participer pourquoi parce que
métisse est et il ya jalil lespert qui
entre en ce moment me paraît un
documentaire un biopic sur sur johnny
c'est d'ailleurs comme ça qu'il s'est
mis en couple avec laeticia il a appelé
un été pour avoir des informations sur
votre jeu ni pour pour son biopic et
puis ils ont fini par échanger des
messages et se finir par se mettre
ensemble ça va en faire moi j'aime pas
ce que benjamin vous le connaissez
personnellement vous l'avez rencontré
dans le cadre d'une interview pour paris
match au début c'est ça non et est ce
que vous direz vous êtes devenus amis on
n'était pas ami avec johnny ouais moi il
a mis des années avant de se souvenir de
mon prénom mais il avait il aimait bien
le savoir est un peu en commun avec toi
m
il aimerait bien avoir un repère à paris
match et c'était moi mais mais voilà
c'était son journal dont qu'il fallait
moi je me suis tapé tous les ans fin
j'étais à toutes les premières parce que
c'était parce que ça fallait juste être
là dans l'entourage et un jour parfois
il avait envie de parler parfois non
mais ça faisait partie du jeu il ya eu
il ya eu plusieurs femmes célèbres et
l'or selon les fans qu'on reçoit ici la
plus célèbre celle où c'est l'autre c
était si pour vous c'est qui la femme de
johnny à sylvie vartan c'est partant à
faire plaisir à laëtitia et
vous voyez quoi ces taxes et adeline
en tout cas elle et ça nous va bien
donc c'est la dernière est celle avec
qui il a passé le plus de temps laetitia
c'est une autre phase de sa vie oui si
l'on peut on peut faire des choses très
clairement sylvie c'est la jeunesse ces
deux gamins qui rencontre un succès
phénoménal après laetitia elle est là
sur les années les plus importantes elle
prend des décisions pour lui parce qu'il
a plus envie de les prendre et elle est
et voilà aujourd'hui on les critique ou
pas mais elle a été extrêmement
importante pour lui et vous même
question qu'est ce qu'on apprend dans le
dock qu'est ce qu'on va voir dans le
dock d'accroître qu'on ne peut que les
téléspectateurs que ne savaient pas ou
n'ont pas vu non mais je sais encore une
fois c'est une plongée dans ses démons
dans ses démons on est d'accord dans ses
démons c'est ce que la nature est ce que
va changer aussi se dopent parce qu'il
ya deux parties dont le dans le clan
hallyday il ya ceux qui sont contre ce
documentaire est ici a notamment mais il
ya aussi ceux qui trouvent que ça va
donner une dimension internationale à
johnny mais parce que netflix est vrai
que ça va être dirigée dans plein de
pays pas tous mais beaucoup et c'est
vrai que nous johnny c'est notre johnny
mais il ya plein de pays européens et
internationaux le cas alors on veut ni
on connaît beaucoup moins non soir par
exemple je ne savais pas c'est que
johnny avait des envies suicidaires
johnny se jette sur une boîte de
barbituriques et se taillader les veines
inconscient johnny était étendu sur la
moquette de la salle de bain du sang
perle à ses poignets ça c'était dans le
livre ni dieu ni diable de gilles dot
c'est vrai ça il est plusieurs fois il a
tenté de se suicider oui oui bien sûr
non non mais c'est ça c'était en
66 je crois à la naissance de hear
entraide de londres où il avait
d'ailleurs
vu jimmy hendrix il avait d'ailleurs
signé un contrat lié à l'idée avait
signé un contrat avec jimi hendrix à
l'oubli on a tendance à l'oublier parce
que pour beaucoup de gens johnny c'est
un peu ringard nana mais on oublie aussi
tout ce qu'il avait déjà connu les
grands plus grands musiciens il a joué
avec les plus grands et il a cette
dimension internationale comme on dit
mais oui il est rentré il était
sylvie lui avait dit que lui avait
annoncé qu'elle voulait divorcer
son gamin venait de neil je crois le
fisc lui réclame et déjà 40 bâton
d'impôts
ça allait pas vraiment je pense qu'il
allait pas quotidien un petit peu oui
enfin des pc avec la drogue et l'alcool
voilà invité et j'ai une question il
paraît il paraît qu'il a eu 4000
maîtresse c'est vrai ça on attend autant
que mick jagger aurait pu donc ça doit
lui même des fruits
c'est incroyable autant jean michel
maire non je me souviens d'un dîner avec
gilles paquet justement qui était capté
tout le temps avec lui gilles clavel
savoir l'histoire où johnny raconter lui
même la soirée où il avait joué à la
roulette russe avec m et donc quand même
devrait rouler trop ce qua non il aurait
pu il aurait pu mourir d'une balle dans
la tête
donc c'était vraiment sexy des et il
devait passer à la fête de l'humanité
ouais ils ont annulé au dernier moment
ce qui fait que
n'était plus du tout camarade avec les
camarades alors benjamin et on parle
aussi de j'aime beaucoup je trouve que
c'est vous et exceptionnel documentaire
que j'ai vu aussi quand il ya deux
lignes blondieau donc selon la ce est la
femme la plus importante là il ya eu
deux mariages et ne dit
non mais c'est vrai que c'est très
important et aline passer un mariage
pharaonique et on n'avait jamais vu ça
vous êtes combien par les alinéas de l a
pas de mauvais mauvais mauvais souvenirs
à 2,2 de johnny quand il rencontre la
ligne les mineurs
gilles est plus à même de raconter cette
histoire parce qu'il n'était plus aux
manettes que moi c'était un délit mineur
est avec le coquin
oui la connaît quand et les murets
laëticia ou sinon bah oui elle était
mineure nord mais j'entends côté
commença à fleurs tout y est c'est un
trou non vous savez pas eu laeticia
aussi noté minty siens quand il est ici
elles étaient mineures au cinéma oui
c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai alors
elle prend aussi beaucoup sur johnny et
les baguettes les bagarres pardon ça
vous pose en parler comme johnny des
bagarres dans le documentaire qu'est ce
qu'on apprend il avait l'alcool mauvais
et donc le verre de trop faisait qui
pouvait vite s'énerver et moi j'ai
assisté à des scènes tardive
effectivement ou y avait toujours un mec
de sa sécurité aux jo peut-être rentrer
là et ils pouvaient se fâcher assez vite
quand il n'était pas content
ça pouvait être assez assez rude il y
avait toujours des gens pour faire en
sorte que ça n'aille pas plus loin il
avait envie de wayne etc donnent à
croire dans un bouquin je ferai de
laurence pieau mais peut-être que vous
voilà où il est sur un bateau il a un
petit peu trop bu et les ti servier le
voir les écoutes mamour ce serait bien
que tu bois un petit peu moins et
donc c'est vrai cette histoire moi
j'étais pas là mais j'en ai j'en ai des
scènes comme ça un jour à los angeles
sortie d'un resto arrive à un français
vous êtes vous êtes geniez de hergé pour
moi et puis là tu me fais chier aller
avait vu le moment où il a eu le footsie
prend dans la gueule et il y avait
sébastien farran qui était son manager
qui l'a pris bon allez on va mais oui la
vie très animal très animal oui et en
plus on s'attend tous à ce que johnny
l'idée soit amateur de grosses bières
machin et tout mais sa boisson préférée
c'était le vin blanc ah oui et j'y vais
je n'ai pas du tout le jeu ni boire de
vin blanc mais ça paraît tout autant
mais tout d'un coup sa marraine était
pas l'alcool ça paraisse apparaît très
très doux ne buvait pas d'alcool moi
pareil ne lui est pas là car petite
anecdote commence à digérer un jour avec
eddy mitchell il arrive et dit lui dit
beaumont johnny tu va peut-être prendre
un petit cocktail non aujourd'hui je
bois pas je vais juste prendre du vin
blanc
aurait qu'une fois dans ma vie et je me
suis retrouvé à une table on était une
dizaine et je vous jure que c'est vrai
j'étais assis à côté c'est le hasard
total de ces tables qu'est ce que je
foutais là me demandez pas je comprenais
quelqu'un de connu c'était pas qui
j'étais et le serveur avait une
bouteille de perrier bouder et 8 buts et
de huy de badoit choix de badoit pendant
la marque et lui dit virez moi cette
merde et moi je pose juste une question
et je vais pas vous n'avez pas la loi et
il répond c'est très mauvais pour la
chanter c'est roches année
[Rires]
la badoit a tué johnny le pardon pour la
marque bien sûr on incitera d'autres
mais je connais pas
effectivement sur la cristalline et s'en
va et guerrier sempé et d'autres en
qu'est ce que vous aimeriez que vous
vraiment en retiennent de ce
documentaire et qu'on retienne de johnny
vous l'avez tellement bien connu bac
c'était quelqu'un d'exceptionnel ouais
c'était un élu quoi elle n'a pas il ya
quoi il ya elvis presley et garnier il
ya quelques personnes comme ça qu'ils
sont pas destinés à être des icônes et
qu'il devienne est
normalement ses démons c'est quoi
c'était un gamin qui a été abandonné par
son père puis par sa mère quitte ensuite
recueilli par sa tante qui part
c'est un enfant du voyage qui part
chanter avec la troupe il y avait eu une
une voyante qui avait dit à sa tante et
les marques il a élevé qui lui avait dit
dans votre famille vous aurez une très
grande star mais une star internationale
elle était persuadée que c'est une de
ses filles mais n'est ni des stars et en
fait c'était le le gamin est à partir ce
moment là n'a pas arrêté il a pris des
cours de guitare il a pris des cours de
danse il à
celui qu'on connaît jamais un dernier
mot quel dommage hein parce qu'une
anecdote me fait marrer et pâques ou
qu'il arrive vous la tienne maison
oui dès qu'il est oui y compris près
qu'il est mais quelque chose le sable
genève un jour journée oui j'aimerais
bien acheté une maison ici bassam papale
juste parce que voilà et c'était son
truc de toujours claquer du blé ou alors
pareil tu aime la moto oui bon ben je
vais en acheter une ou alors que fayet
toujours ce besoin de dire je vais te
diront je vais mais raide et je vais
donner comme s'il était gêné d'avoir
trop de données qu'ils ont à faire
non je lui ai offert un coffret des
stones pour son anniversaire il a
regardé mes yeux bleus
merci encore à gym l'adversaire a duré
des heures
[Applaudissements]